welcome to this video Guerrero da Luz
yep recently lost the game against the
sky I don't remember what it was mm-hmm
really don't okay I'm trying the
Kalashnikov again yah my rating has gay
got a healthy boost recently here again
over 2400 there are those kind of yeah I
have those runs that you cannot explain
sometimes um okay can I take on e4 here
okay I just just take first and ask
later I really hope it works shadow is
there is their tactic i think i think i
actually lost exactly like that once
this happens if you don't think i should
have thought for just one moment stupid
stupid stupid
Graham's an idiot yeah what what time
was i thinking really am it's kind of
useless yeah what a game may you you
lose after 10 move just because you want
to play quitting for once and I think I
lost exactly like that in some some
older game yeah of course I can also
resign but maybe I can punish myself a
little bit now well as long as he is ok
to see how I don't know what let's take
their land and sea at least I'm I'm
close to a spy check here check I can't
like Queen a3 all the time
check yeah yeah it's a whole real crunch
yeah I'm just continuing because i
played this so horribly maybe he may be
a false from the channel laughing or
something
yeah what the game plan resides yeah if
you're really 94 idiot yeah justjust
blunders a piece yeah for nothing okay I
think I exactly i lost exactly like that
once but i forgot it yeah it is a tactic
that sometimes this work but here's a
screen age five yeah yeah known game
really yeah i don't know castle is
probably very often you can give this
pawn something something like that also
I don't know this is very often quite
decent compensation but well I don't
really know the opening that well would
need to to to look look up some things
we should be six year or so this comes
into consideration I don't know the
precise move on here maybe 90 of six
what do I think I think this is the
right move water well I don't know but
you definitely cannot take only for
which was proven very convincingly okay
thanks for watching